on a toujours et on continue à dire
qu'il faut mettre l'argent dans la
recherche pour essayer de justifier si
vous voulez tous les indications et tous
les bénéfices qu'on donne au cannabis et
par balles le maquis en a mais ce n'est
pas encore complètement démontrer
un médecin doit
voir les connaissances quand il prescrit
un produit sûr pas de formation s'ils
ont peu suivi une formation qui dans le
domaine s'y connaît absolument pas parce
que vous savez actuellement le cannabis
c'est un petit peu flou la dose la forme
pour telle pathologie
alors donc il va avoir des formations
qui vont être faites il va faire pour
les médecins il ya déjà des médecins qui
ont suivi ces formations là et qui en
prescrivent alors ils vont pouvoir si
vous voulez fort mais aussi d'autres
médecins pour le faire
sauf qu'au médecin sait que ça va
devenir très créatif et le danger c'est
que le monde qui en veulent sur le point
de vue récréatif à celle de l'échelle
sans chercher du point de vue médicaux
si c'était rembourser voudrait l'avoir
gratis pour des offres des objectifs
récréatif alors voyez vous il faut faire
attention vont pas tomber dans ce
panneau là et on dit à nos membres
d'être très très très prudent puis de le
faire jusqu'à maintenant on le faisait
dans un cadre de projets de recherche
l'on va être un petit peu plus ouvert
mais par contre il faut quand même être
strict faire un suivi rigoureux